Speaker 1: Failed former President Donald Trump
delivered a lie riddled all capital letters,
endorsement of sorts of Kevin McCarthy for
speaker of the House. Now, before we look at
Trump's post to truth social.
Speaker 2: Growth, Sanjay.
Speaker 1: I should tell you kind of the
backstory. Story of what was going on.
Kevin McCarthy yesterday failed, as I told
you, in three votes to secure the 218 votes,
he needs to become the speaker of the House.
Embarrassing, humiliating, actually losing support
as the votes went on. Yesterday, Donald Trump told
NBC News or rather didn't tell nbc news whether he
still supported Kevin McCarthy. But Trump took
a little bit of time, I guess, to think about
it or more likely to be told what it is that he
should say. And this morning, he did come out with
a three post tirade, untruth essential. Where,
again, we're interpreting Trump's bizarre language
and syntax. I guess he's saying he supports Kevin
McCarthy. Trump posting, quote, Some really good
conversations took place last night. I think that
means someone told him what to do. But okay, some
really good conversations took place last night
and it's now time for all of our great Republican
House members. And here he goes. Caps lock to
vote for Kevin. Close the deal, take the victory
and watch crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back home to a
very broken California, the only speaker in U.S.
history to have lost the House twice. Republicans
do not turn a great triumph into a giant,
embarrassing defeat. It's time to celebrate. You
deserve it. Kevin McCarthy will do a good job,
maybe even a great job. Just watch. Now, it's
important to mention this has nothing to do
with Nancy Pelosi. Trump is obsessed with Pelosi.
Pelosi said she is stepping down from leadership.
Democrats don't control the House. She's not
asking to be minority leader. This has nothing
to do with Pelosi. But Trump is obsessed with
Pelosi. And by the way, it's funny. He says
McCarthy will do a good job. Maybe it'll even
be great. I don't know. Not exactly a ringing
endorsement. Trump then adding also on troth
essential quote If Republicans are going to fight,
we ought to be fighting Mitch McConnell
and his domineering, China loving boss,
I mean wife, Coco Chao. Trump continuing with
the racial epithets or as some wrongly call them,
epitaphs, which is a completely different thing.
The harm they have done to the Republican Party
is incalculable. Today, he couldn't be
elected dogcatcher in Kentucky. Sadly,
he only won because of my endorsement. Went
up 21 points. Sorry. And then lastly, Trump
going back to caps lock. Take the victory and
run, says Donald Trump. Trump waited to decide,
does he stick with Kevin McCarthy or not?
Apparently he decided yes, he sticks with him,
but falling a little bit short of a full throated
ringing endorsement. We saw others last night
seemingly taking baby steps away from Kevin
McCarthy. This includes propagandist Tucker
Carlson. This includes propagandist Sean HANNITY
and others that we will get to after this short
break. Remember next Wednesday, January 11th, 6
p.m. Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific. We will be doing
the first viewer townhall of 2023. I hope that you
will join us live. Everyone is invited to call in.
Our members will get priority access to talk to
me. You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
remember. Always remember. Subscribe to the
YouTube channel. Folks, 3 million of you watched
our clips last month and did not subscribe. Hit
that subscribe button. Help us get to 2 million.